on va tout de suite prendre la direction
de l'extrême ouest de l'ukraine à lviv
où nous attend notre envoyé spécial
gulliver craag bonsoir gulliver je le
disais le vivre c'est à l'extrême ouest
de l'ukraine et la situation on imagine
est bien différente ici de ce qui se
passe ailleurs dans le pays que l'hiver
oui le vivent est devenue la ville de
repli si vous voulez pour des missions
diplomatiques des entreprises des médias
et aussi beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui ont
trouvé reçu refuge ici il y a un
semblant de vie normale dans cette ville
les distributeurs de billets de banque
par exemple fonctionne on peut parfois
payer par carte s'il y a beaucoup de
monde ici dans le centre historique de
lviv c'est parce que il y a tellement de
gens qui sont venus d'ailleurs en
ukraine cette place est normalement
remplis de touristes pendant toutes les
saisons de l'année c'est vraiment la
ville la plus touristique de l'ukraine
mais aujourd'hui bien sûr ce ne sont pas
des touristes qui sont ici mais des gens
qui sont très inquiet pour ce qui se
passe pour beaucoup d'entre eux dans
leur ville natale dont les endroits où
ils ont quittés et où ils ont parfois
laissé de la famille est donc
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens ont regardé
avec terreur les scènes de marioupol où
on a entendu que un cessez le feu qui
devait permettre une évacuation de cette
ville qui a été terriblement bombardé et
par par l'armée russe cette ville
portuaire dont le double bass et bien
l'évacuation a dû être suspendue parce
que le cessez-le-feu n'a pas eu lieu les
les attaques ont continué et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui conforte le
sentiment que beaucoup d'ukrainiens
avaient déjà qu'ils étaient juste pensé
on ne peut jamais faire confiance à ce
que les russes disent même quand il
s'agit d'un couloir humanitaire
les nouvelles de certains autres villes
dans le sud de l'ukraine sont un petit
peu meilleure puisqu'il y avait
visiblement des manifestations contre
l'occupation russe dont deux villes
occupées personnes et berlioz que des
foules assez importantes sont descendus
pour dire que pour eux cette ville
restait une craignant est aussi selon le
gouverneur de la région de mikolajki est
une autre grande ville du sud ciblés par
les russes eh bien les forces
l'ukrainienne aurait repoussé une
attaque sur cette ville aujourd'hui ce
sont des propos du gouverneur de la
région reporter dans les médias
ukrainiens qui reste à confirmer
du leader pendant pendant ce temps-là
volodymyr hélène ce qui lui est resté à
kiev il a lancé un appel aux
ukrainiennes appelle à l'espoir mais il
a aussi critiqué l'otan il sa volonté de
ne pas mettre en place de zones
d'exclusion aérienne au dessus de
l'ukraine 1
oui on a l'impression que vladimir
zelensky vraiment dans tout ce qu'il
peut pour essayer de convaincre les pays
de l'otan d'imposer cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne et les même allé
jusqu'à dire dans une vidéo qu'il a
sorti tard hier soir que dorénavant tous
morts civils en ukraine serait sur la
conscience des leaders des pays de
l'otan s'il n'imposait pas cette zone
s'il ne fermait pas le ciel au dessus de
l'ukraine s'est il faut souligner aussi
que volodymyr et l'inscrit qui n'était
pas extrêmement populaire avant le début
de cette guerre est maintenant louer par
presque tous les ukrainiens du moins
tous les ukrainiens que je connais la
plupart des ukrainiens que je connais
personnellement n'ont pas voté pour
volodymyr zelensky aux réalités
maintenant je pense qu'il voterait pour
lui il est extrêmement populaire son
courage est vraiment saluée par tout le
pays c'est très impressionnant
merci beaucoup gulliver craag envoyé
spécial de france 24 à lviv à l'extrême
ouest de l'ukraine